[Music]
welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from google cloud we are
hosting webinars every tuesday
my name is eulon lin and today i'll be
talking about custom visualizations and
data studio
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have googlers on standby
to answer them
let's get started so today i'm going to
be talking about how you would build
custom visualizations
in data studio so i'm a developer
advocate i work on data studio and if
you want to follow along with anything
i'm saying here
or learn more go to
developers.google.com data studio
visualization just a quick
overview of the things that i intend to
talk about today i want to
give a quick intro to data studio for
those of you who may not be as familiar
with it
and then talk about what community
visualizations are
what this custom visualization feature
is give a conceptual overview
so what are some of the things the
terminology you need to know to
understand it
and then walk you through how to build
one there might even be some live coding
involved
and then some conclusions and next steps
for you all to take
so data studio is google's business
intelligence platform it's free
it allows you to create dashboards that
are really easy to read
to share and to customize and so when we
think about the things that data studio
allows you to do
you can connect to a whole variety of
data sources so if you go to
datastudio.google.com
data you'll see a whole bunch of
connectors where you can connect
to data sources things that we've
written here at google
things that our partners have written
and if you don't see what you want there
we also provide ways for you to write
your own custom connectors
so that you can connect to different
data sources we also provide ways for
you to analyze your data
what does it look like to find insights
to combine different data sources
to do some calculations i also find ways
to visualize data
right so different chart types tables
pivot tables
and then finally sharing who needs to
see the report
we make that really really easy for you
to distribute it among the people that
need to see it
so enough talking about it i'm going to
pop over to data studio and just show
you really quickly what that looks like
so this is just datastudio.google.com
and i'm going to create a blank report
and i'm going to use the sample google
analytics data
that everyone has access to
and up here you can see that there's a
bunch of chart types
so you can make a time series a bar
chart combo chart pie chart so i'm just
going to make
a pie chart because i just had too much
pie over the weekend
area chart and maybe add
some text
so while i'm here i just want to point
out one thing which is that
we support a whole bunch of chart types
up here but there's no way that we can
support
every chart type under the sun
everything that you would want to be
able to tell stories with your data
and if you look here on the styling too
we provide a lot of different styling
options
right but there's not always a way for
you to
do everything that you could possibly
dream up
and this is where community
visualizations come in
right so what if you want other charts
what if you want other options
and so this is this is what community
visualizations are really great for
and to show you an example of one that
i've built
we're going to go back to data studio
and i'm going to enter a component id
which is basically telling data studio
like i've written this other code please
go load it please go fetch it so that i
can make charts with it
and so as it's thinking about the report
once you've written the code you can
distribute this id
this location to whoever else might be
interested
in using the community visualization or
in the custom visualization
and as it continues thinking
and so it would just be
the same as configuring any other chart
in data studio where you can select
the dimensions you want the metrics
you're interested in and the styling
since it doesn't really want to load for
me right now i'm actually going to pop
back over to my slides
tell you more about it and hope that it
likes me a little bit more in a few
minutes
so a conceptual overview of community
visualizations what's actually happening
under the hood when i click that load
button when i enter in that id
so when you load up community
visualization the end user is providing
a component id
which is basically saying hey data
studio this is where to find the
metadata about my visualization
so data studio then goes to read the
package data
and it says like okay this is what i
know about who wrote it
this is where i can find the other code
and all the resources that i need for it
then data studio will load the
visualization resources so it goes and
finds
okay you told me that this is where i
can find the javascript the css
the configuration um i'm going to load
them in now
and then once it's loaded the iframe
tells data studio hey i'm ready for some
data and styling information
and then data studio provides that data
and style information
so that the code you've written the
javascript code you've written
can render the visualization so
transforming that data and styling
information that the end user has
provided
into a really cool visualization
so what are the big steps involved in
building and using community
visualizations
so the first is that you have to write
the code so writing the code involves a
couple different things which i'll walk
through in a sec
then you have to upload the
visualization resources so right now we
only support google cloud platform but
broadly the idea is
put the resources somewhere where data
studio can get to them so that we can
load them into your report
and then finally loading the
visualization in data studio what does
it look like
to take all the code you've written and
see it integrate with a dashboard
so first i'm going to talk about writing
the visualization code
and the different things that are
associated with that
so there's three steps to writing a
visualization you have to write a
configuration json
you have to write the visualization code
and package the visualization
so we're going to dive right in and
think about what the configuration json
is
why it's important so the configuration
json
defines two things it defines data
options
and styling options so it's essentially
a json with
two keys it's a data key and that
configures
the data side of the property panel so
it's stuff like
how many metrics does my visualization
support how many dimensions does my
visualization support
do i want someone to only be able to use
one dimension and one metric or should
it be
one dimension and between one and three
metrics and actually like
these metrics should be named something
really specific to the use case so that
the end user knows what kind of metric
to put in so all of that happens
in the data section and you'll see an
example of that later
with styling it's stuff like this that
you would see on the
style tab of the property panel so
things like i want to name a check box
should
should i show labels or i want the end
user to be able to change the color
of my bar chart and i want them to use a
fill
picker for that we support a whole bunch
of styling
icons that allow the end user to
interact with them and then data studio
will send that
whatever they pick back to your
visualization so that's what the
configuration
json does and this config does two
things
right one is i just talked about it
impacts how the property panel renders
so it impacts how many dimensions the
end user can put in
how many metrics they can put in what
styling options are available to them
but the other thing it does is it allows
the developer to know what keys to use
to access the data later
so not only am i saying like providing
provide me one dimension
but i'll say like provide me one
dimension and under the hood i'm gonna
call it
dim1 so that when i go to access it
later
in my visualization code i'm gonna say
like i'm gonna use dim1 in my code
um same with styling right so if i
define a
font color picker for the color of my
text i'll call it
maybe text color and then i can go back
in my code later
and say give me the text color thing
that the end user selected
the next thing is to write the
javascript code so what goes into the
viz code
there's three components that are
necessary for
the actual visualization code itself one
is the data studio helper library
we've provided a javascript library that
abstracts out some of the interfacing
with
our api and so that's one piece of it
the second is any javascript
visualization library you might be
interested in using
there's a million out there you all
probably know of d3
chart js you might even have some that
are internal to your own company
and finally there's the viz code that
you write
and so these three combined goes into
the viz code
optionally there's a css file where you
can provide additional styling guidance
to the iframe
and like the code that you would write
within that that's not
the helper library that's not
visualization packages is gonna broadly
look like
this this the cons dscc require
at google dscc that's just saying that
i'm including
the data studio helper library that
helps me write a visualization
um and then i define a callback i'm
going to call it drawchart here
and that's i'm just going to say like
hey give me the height give me the width
so i know
the dimensions of the canvas that i get
to work with
and then subscribe to the data so that
this draw chart function is called
every time there's an update to the data
or to the style information that the end
user is selecting
inside the property panel another
required argument to this subscribe to
data function
is a transform just to understand what
data format would be most useful
for you and if you go to dev site and
you'll see the url later
the specifics of what that object looks
like and what information you get is all
there
so next you have to upload the
visualizations to google cloud platform
so you just have a google cloud platform
bucket you put your stuff there
and again broadly the idea is i need to
put my code somewhere that data studio
can get to it
um and so right now it's
google cloud platform so you put it in
and then
using the location of where you've put
things in google cloud platform
loading the visualization into data
studio
so loading a visualization let's see if
data studio likes me just a little bit
more now
um
and i'm going to try to load a sankey
diagram i'm going to
clear the canvas so there's a little bit
more space
and you see here that i've defined that
this visualization can take two
dimensions so i'm going to go ahead
put in continent gender
and then play with some of the styling
so as it decides to load
i'm actually going to refresh it so not
only did i define in this visualization
that i wanted the end user to be able to
configure
two dimensions and a metric but i also
wanted them to be able to select
different styling options
for example the node color
and the link color and since this
doesn't seem like it wants to load right
now
i'm gonna go to
um can i show you some of these
visualizations that i fill so this is
the one i'm
trying to load
but here you see this is the sankey
chart i have two dimensions i have a
metric
and then here in the style pack panel
there's a bunch of different things you
can do with the colors so
i've said you can play with the node
color
whether or not you show the node labels
change the font size and the label
offset
so that whoever else wants to use this
visualization can configure all of these
things
without ever having to touch the
visualization code
so that's what that looks like
going back to that tab you'll see it's
finally decided to load so that's
that's how you would load it so now
what i want to do might be a dangerous
proposition when i'm doing this on a
live stream
is to show you how i would build a
visualization
and so generally when i build
visualizations i'm starting from
something that already exists
so yesterday i took some time to build
a histogram using d3 so
i'm just going to show you what that
looks like locally
so it's a histogram i have buckets
i have i use the counts of things in
those buckets
to determine the bar height but what i'm
going to do now is i want to be able to
load
this visualization in a data studio
report
so to be able to do that i need to
define a couple things
remember when i was talking about
earlier the first thing to do is to
define the configuration
well with the um
so with the histogram right
naively the simplest thing i can think
of is i want an index dimension
that just deaggregates my data and so i
just tell data studio
i'm going to call it index this is the
id that i'm going to use to access it in
my code later
i'm going to do this label thing called
index
and this is the label that shows up in
the property panel when the end user
loads it
so they know they're loading it into
something i'm calling index
it expects that it's a dimension type
and under options i'm saying
you have to have at least one of one
field populated in here and you have to
have a maximum of one field populated in
here
and then i'm doing the same thing for a
metric and saying this is the thing i'm
going to
figure out the distribution of right and
again i want only one of these so i'm
going to say min max of one
and so this project is set up with a
little bit of template code and a little
bit of
scripting so that i can just deploy
things
run and so what i'm doing here
is i'm just saying i'm just telling data
studio to build it
and so once i did once i have done that
it would show i would be able to see
those things
show up in the data where i would be
able to say
scrolling up that there's one dimension
and it's called index
and one metric and it's called sessions
um and then the thing i would do in
order to
convert the histogram code from
something that was run
locally to something that is running
maybe in data studio
is to add the data studio community
component library that's the helper
library
and to use that to interface with the
data instead of maybe hard-coding it
like i did
for the initial demo
so
so this is just like the setup for what
i would do
here and this is this is where i'm
converting the data
from whatever data studio expects to
what my visualization expects
and i'm just saying hey take the data
from whatever it was before into what i
know my visualization will take
i'm gonna populate this job is and just
copy paste all the
code that i had previously into it um
and then this is the this is the disc
subscribe to data
where i'm telling data studio hey draw
this visualization run this draw viz
function every time i get a new set of
data and styling options
so
so here i'm saying i want d3
and then for draw viz
i'm just going to copy over that all of
that code
essentially and say
instead of height i'm going to say
hey data studio give me the height of
the iframe because the iframe could
change
because the user might decide that they
want to move things around and where
they report or resize things
right and so the height of the
visualization
isn't necessarily something you want to
fix and dscc
and then change the width
um to do that and then instead of the
data being some kind of hard-coded
sample data
and so that's really all it takes to
take something from
like a visualization that you've used
elsewhere or written to run locally
into something that um into something
that
data you can load into a data studio
report
so let's go back here
see
and i think that's what i called it
um
um and so what that looks like here you
can see that there's an
index um and that's what supposedly is
de-aggregate
de-aggregating my data this particular
data set isn't quite set up that way
and then a metric and so i can interact
with it
play with it as if i was
as if i was interacting with any other
data studio visualization and then here
in the style um
panel i have this thing called a um like
a
a color picker and if i really wanted to
um i could then i can pick this now i
haven't set up the visualization to take
the styling information from it
but then i could go back in and the way
i would do that in the code
is just to say figure out where i set
the color of the bar
i think it's fill and then
here i would just call it i think
let's see this data dot style
and i think i called it bar color
and then that would be the only it's a
one-line change in the code for me to be
able to take
um the the color that the end user
selects
and have it show up in the visualization
so going back um just built a
visualization
what are some of the takeaways from this
one is that the community visualization
this custom visualization feature gives
you a blank canvas and data to play with
essentially we're handing you an iframe
and saying like what cool things can you
build with your data
and and so you can do things even with
like web audio
and such and webgl
and the other thing is that the
configuration files allow you to expose
options to the end user right which
means that your end user doesn't need to
know how to code doesn't need to know d3
or any other
javascript chart libraries in order to
use what you've built
and if you expose certain options they
can have a lot of freedom and
flexibility
even within that without ever having to
go back and dig through the viz code
so thanks i hope you all go build a
visualization you can find all the
documentation
and tutorials on how to do it at
developers.google.com
data studio visualization if you build
something cool share it on social media
with the hashtag datastudiodevs
and you can find me on twitter at y3l2n
stay tuned for live q a we will be back
in less than a minute
welcome back so let's answer a couple
questions about community visualizations
and data studio
um so the first question is can i use
non-javascript libraries like python's
matplotlib
or maybe rsggplot2 and the answer to
that is no
we only allow you to load javascript
within an iframe because
of the nature of how things are set up
next thing is how can we only let
certain users use my visualization
right now we don't have a way to do that
except by limiting who knows
where the resources live and who knows
that visualization id
and so but that is something we're
looking forward to working on
in the near future um the next thing is
like what data sources work with
community visualizations
and that's basically anything
as long as the data source owner allows
it um
because we want to make sure that people
are aware that these are created by the
community and by third party folks
and if you want to and for the next
thing where can you find
code examples for community
visualizations if you want to
see examples of community visualizations
or see working examples from the
documentation
we have a github so if you go to
github.com google data studio
slash community visualizations you'll be
able to see
some examples of things that are up on
our website
and then finally like how do you test
the visualization as you build it
and so that's the thing i was kind of
already doing is like as i was building
it loading it
um and so a lot of it is just like
loading it as you go
if you wanted to maintain separate dev
and prod deployment so that
people who are using your code aren't
broken as you try to add new features
i would just recommend having two
separate
locations of your resources and just
managing them yourself
that's all for today please tune in next
tuesday for the next cloudonair and
thank you all for watching
you